what's goodie hot breath verse welcome
back to hot breath the show where you
learn comedy from the pros i am your
host comedian joel byers and our mission
here is to cultivate the next generation
of great comics by interviewing today's
great comics and our guest today is a
living success story of that diy comedy
hustle we talk about so much on this
show she started comedy at 16 where she
was doing homework at open mics but by
the time she was 19 she had already
befriended george carlin taking him out
to coffee which will definitely get into
but throughout her 20-plus year career
now she has self-produced
albums comedy specials she's written her
own books she's booked her own comedy
tours around the world this is a
comedian who has created her own success
and is here to help you
and me
do the same so please welcome to the hot
breath the verse liz mealy hi
welcome when you put it all together i
feel really proud of myself you should
it's incredible
even to think that you want to start at
16. i always thought i was funny but
then didn't start till i was 22. so
how'd you take the leap so soon i
definitely didn't think i was funny i i
think i just i wanted to do it and i
thought
well if it doesn't work out
i have my whole life ahead of me oh yeah
you know what i mean like you know like
because i do feel bad i have a lot of
friends that started when they were 30
and there's just like this like rush in
this like i don't know this like
not i mean we're all eager but like this
like it has to work out and mine was
like
i hope it works out like if it doesn't i
guess i'll get a job like
and then as i continue to do it more i
was like i don't want a job i'm gonna
try yeah but you're you're 16 both your
parents are veterinarians what do they
say that you're like i want to go to new
york and do
yeah i mean the first couple of times i
went i lied and then eventually i told
them and i'm one of five kids and i was
like kind of the crazy cat lady so i was
the one they really thought was like
gonna fill their shoes
um which is interesting because they
just retired this year and my dad was
like i'm so glad you didn't become a vet
we made so much money selling the
practice and we wouldn't have made that
money if you kept it and i was like i
didn't ever want to work with you
i barely wanted to be raised by you
so um but it's it's really nice that
when i did finally tell them they were
actually really supportive like my mom
just doesn't care like like now she
loves it like she comes to shows and she
loves all the jokes about her even when
they're like disparaging she's like i'll
just pretend it's someone else and i was
like mom we have the same face like
there's nobody else
um
but
for the longest time my dad was
supportive
while trying to get me to be financially
stable and by that and i think a lot of
people's parents are like that words
like you can play around but maybe you
get a part-time job or hey you do this
but you can still do your comment like
this kind of meal a deal like you know
you can have your fun but also make sure
you pay your bills and so i was still
paying my bills when i was full time it
was just [__] stressful and i think i
shielded them from a lot of that like
paying my rent 50 gigs at a time stress
because i wanted them to believe that i
was
fine but i really only started to be
financially fine
maybe five years ago wow you know you've
been doing that 20 years it's oh it is
20 exactly okay i knew it had been a
while so 15 years to feel stability and
comedy yeah because i'm 12 years in and
i can attest that i'm working towards
that yeah yeah and it's also what you
define as stability so there might be
some people that look at the money i
make and think oh that's not good enough
but i'm making what my friends are
making with master's degrees and it took
me longer than their education and i've
been doing this longer but i also
learned on the job so you if you look at
it like i was in school for the first
five or so years of it and literally in
school i was in college high school and
college in the beginning so you're in
school and you're doing open mics and
you're doing you know these bar shows
and whatever and then you get into the
internship phase where like you you
don't have to pay to do stand-up but
you're getting these guest spots at
clubs and maybe you're you know more
people are seeing you and your hosting
and whatever kind of little bit there
and then you start featuring and that's
its own education while also making some
money but then you know you have to sell
t-shirts to make a living because it's
not real money and it's like it was that
so and then i straddled i was always
straddling the line i was hosting some
places and featuring some places i was
featuring some places and i was
headlining some places you know i was
headlining but i didn't have a fan base
and now i'm at this place where like
headliner fan base i can book my own
theaters if i don't feel like a club is
giving me the deal i want
i'm able to make money through royalties
with all the albums and specials i have
out i have a book um you know i have so
many different means of making money off
my past accomplishments and then with
touring and writing and all that kind of
stuff so i think i lived a very small
life and i was able to live just off
comedy
you know a lot sooner than some people
because i tried to budget and keep
things small because all i wanted to do
was stand up but it was small it was a
small life it was like oh no my car got
towed and i'm [__] like you know what
i mean like you know 700 later and i'm
like i don't know if i can pay my rent
next month so it was a lot of that and
nobody likes feeling that way and now
my car can get towed a couple of times
like i don't want to brag or anything
i got carto money i got making a lot of
mistakes money
um and that's where i feel comfortable
which is that i feel like i'm being paid
for my value both in the present value
of what i'm giving you today but also in
the fact that i have 20 years behind me
and you get frustrated sometimes or
somebody gives you an offer and you're
like first of all it took me a year to
write this hour so it's a year of work
not just an hour of my time that's a
year of work then it took 20 years for
you to know who i am want me
specifically and for me to be good
enough that that hour is something that
you want i'm not accepting this money
and if this is outside of your budget
here are a bunch of people that would
probably do it for less but it's not
going to be me and that took a long time
too and i think
i
i'm very fortunate because my parents
both were veterinarians and my you know
they own their
animal hospital i have both a creative
sense i feel like i have tenacity
because my parents kind of pave the way
for themselves but also i like creative
business i like i like writing the
emails i like getting better at
negotiating i like making posters i like
finding out what um fans are noticing
and not noticing in my promotional stuff
do i want to do that forever absolutely
not but i do take pride in every aspect
of how my career has gone because i have
been that hands-on and that
do-it-yourself kind of person and
self-taught i mean like your your video
that went viral you studied or the first
one that went viral was it the feminist
sex positions the one the first one that
went viral yeah but like you self-taught
uh like pr and you like taught yourself
social media like you really business
you've read a lot of business books so
like this isn't just someone who's been
writing and developing as a comedian but
you've really like self-taught the
entire almost like ecosystem of what it
takes to become a comedian now yeah and
i think it's what it always took to
become a comedian but um
now it has more resources because before
it you know because the internet or like
youtube or you know instagram tic tac
all those things weren't as prevalent
you know it was festivals it was being
on other people's show posters it was um
just being a name people knowing who you
are like i remember so distinctly you
know i went on facebook
it had just opened up it was like a
thing that only college kids were doing
and when i joined it i think it was
actually a year after college i was
probably like 22 years old i didn't
really know what to do with it so in the
beginning i would just post that i had
shows so i would be like hey i'm gonna
be at you know this bar doing this show
tonight and hey i'm gonna be at this
club doing this thing tonight and i
would just every day post where i was
gonna be and then i would see people in
the real world and they've been like
you've been getting up a lot but nothing
had changed i was always a hustler i was
always trying to do as many spots and i
would say yes to everything it's just
now people could visually see how much i
was doing and so there's a lot of this
kind of
face time like you should do facetime
when you're at a bar when you're around
a club whatever whatever i never really
did facetime i did performance time i
would ask people if i could be on their
shows i would um
write to people and say can i be on your
shows i would you know kind of
figure out any way that i could be on
somebody's show
but you know the goal was to be on
posters and to have people know my name
but i don't really drink i didn't wasn't
a big drinker when i was younger and now
i don't drink at all i have social
anxiety
i still am struggling to like go to
parties by myself so this idea of
sitting at a bar and waiting for the
booker that everybody's hounding and i
don't have any value in this person's
eyes i was like i'm not going to do that
i'm going to go out and get value and so
i found social media was a way of doing
face time without all the social anxiety
so i could say hey i'm going to be at
this club hey
i'm working on this thing hey this is a
funny thing i did and now i'm constantly
in people's feeds and it's an everyday
face time as opposed to i'm at a bar and
i'm like
[Music]
i'm gonna go you're like waiting in line
and then it's your turn and you're like
never mind yeah yeah and they're like
how are you doing you're like
i'm doing stuff i know it seems like i'm
not busy and then um i don't know if you
uh so amy um
she's one of the uh bookers uh at um new
york comedy club and she's a friend of
mine i've known her forever but she
started doing this thing on her i think
it's her personal instagram maybe not
the club's instagram where she's just
kind of giving young comics tips
anything from like how to hold the mic
to whatever and she posted something a
couple of months ago that was like um
you know when you sit at the bar doing
this facetime you know what that tells
me
you're not working
and that's how i always felt and it felt
so good to be like validated in that
perspective because that's how i felt
you've been at a bar for four hours she
knows it's a friday night and you're not
working
go [__] work go do three open mics so
that's was always my perspective both in
a i don't know how to survive that way
of doing it and being buddy buddy and
i'm not fun so i couldn't be fun and i
couldn't be somebody that wanted to have
fun with so i was just going to go get
good and that's the stuff i want to do i
don't want to hang out a bar i want to
go do stand up so even if it's a shitty
open mic it was still moving the needle
even an inch forward yeah i'll get asked
that a lot too of like from younger
comics of like well is this show worth
it or whatnot and i i feel like the
first several years of your career you
literally should be on anywhere at any
time every show yes even if it's trash
you learn something from it now
eventually it becomes the law of
diminishing returns we'll all do a show
and i'm not getting paid well the
audience is shitty i can't try new stuff
i'm angry um i'm i feel like it's a
waste of my time and now i won't do
those shows but i feel like there are
things that still make me stretch and
that's important but yeah there's
certain things that i won't do anymore
but it took me like
six or seven years for the first no yeah
to be at a show where i did it i did it
three times everywhere so it was close
to me it was like a three-minute walk
from my apartment when i lived in the
east village and i did it and i was like
that wasn't fun but the guy was a friend
that ran it so you know a month later he
asked me to do it again and i was like
that wasn't fun and i did a third time
and i was like
i think i might be better than this room
yeah like that was like the first time
that i was like it's not fun
i'm not they're like so loud and so
rowdy i'm not like able to really even
do my act i can't work on new stuff
i'm not doing this anymore and it was
like so like you know and i have to
weigh the options and i gave him i gave
it three chances you know i might not
give three chances again but like i i'm
i i really think in the beginning being
comfortable on stage takes a lot of time
getting the words down um um how you
function in different rooms like i find
it so funny that some people just hug
one room they're like i feel most
comfortable in this room and you're like
yeah but if your dream is to tour you
need to learn to be comfortable in every
room you need to make every room
comfortable so i i feel fortunate that i
took every stage time from open mics to
bringer shows to barking to get stand up
you know to guest spots to you know
just doing things for [__] money like i
took everything in the beginning
tell us a little bit of the reality of
like the self-made hustle it's it's cool
to see now like that you have done all
these amazing things and i mean that's
been my journey 12 years i've produced
my own tours my own comedy special album
like this podcast we've been doing for
five years like so it's been a lot of
self-made that people like oh that's
cool but the reality is like oh
self-made is it's like all on self as
well and like what are those highs and
lows of that yeah it's it's exhausting
and i just i i've in and out had
managers throughout my career but very
boutique managers i had like kind of a
bigger manager a couple of years ago and
then she kind of left the business and
then um i didn't get an agent until
october of 2020. wow i started in 2002.
[Laughter]
you know it took 18 years so this i
always kind of have this like smirk on
my face whenever i hear a comic that's
like i'm trying to get an agent and i'm
like
good luck with that if that is your goal
good luck with that but it's going to
hurt you if it doesn't come easy it does
come easy to some people i wasn't one of
them
um
and
even when you have them they only can do
so much like one of the things that i
felt
uh
very good about and felt very flattering
is when my booking agent picked me up
and it was like you know an acting ager
a lit agent a booking agent and then i
have um
my manager now as well but um he was
like i like your hustle he's like i like
that he's like you can still book
whatever you want to book you know keep
me in the loop but you know if if the
deal i'm getting you isn't what you want
let's figure out a better way like but
like
i
even with my agents and they do a great
job there's still a lot of things that
i'm still doing myself because it's it's
they're they're taking care of several
comics i'm the only person taking care
of me i have more time i have more
energy um uh i'm willing to have you
know spend money on stuff so like i
hired a pr for my special that's coming
out um i'm the one that's you know even
with my pr i'm still reaching out to all
the connections i have for certain
podcasts and stuff like that like i've
never you know i've relaxed a little bit
in some sense and i do have a team now
but i'm still
70 percent
on and doing a lot of it myself wow
that's incredible and i i interviewed
tamara goins who is the head of comedy
at innovative artists and she said that
you'll have a get a manager when you
have something to manage yes it's like
young comics are like i need someone to
put me on or whatnot but literally like
now it's i mean social media
is really where all the leverage is now
but you know when i was the reason i got
into social media is because i had a
manager and he didn't leave the business
he took this different jump that he
couldn't bring with me
bring me with him and he was gone and
then i couldn't get another manager and
um i wasn't getting the work that i
wanted to get i wasn't getting on tv the
way i felt i should it was right after i
had been on live at gotham on comedy
central and i had done a [__] on
auditions but it didn't turn into
anything
and
i just felt alone i just felt like [__]
i it's been 10 years and i just feel
stuck and i hit a wall and then i
started to think well
maybe i'll make social media my manager
if the point of a manager is for them to
get your name out there and the point of
social media
you know is to get your name out there
i'll just do that and that's when i
started reading every social media book
i read gary vaynerchuk's first book
which was called crush it um
i couldn't even tell you when it came
out so if it's 2022 i guess 2012 2011
like you know it's a thin little book
and i read that book um i read groups
which is about how social media is just
word of mouth and so if you understand
how friendship works and how old school
word of mouth works you'll understand
how this new school word of mouth works
um because you know before it was like
oh have you seen that new tom cruise
movie and then it's like oh you went to
the movies what did you see oh i saw the
tom cruise you know what i mean it's so
it's the same thing it's just quicker
and and spreads farther than your friend
group and your family
so um
ryan holiday had a book um
there was i read everything i read
everything from like managers like the
biggest managers in the industry that
like wrote about what they did in the
music industry to you know um just
social media books or whatever and you
know you don't do everything you can't
do everything and a lot of the stuff was
for corporations in the beginning it
wasn't even for artists like now stuff
is more tailored to artists and
comedians specifically in the beginning
it was like you're colgate this is how
you get people to buy your brand so now
i have to be like what would i do as
colgate that
pertains to me and someone that has
albums so i had to like even translate
what was already out there because it
wasn't really made for artists but you
know
the highs are when it works out you know
what i mean like i took this pr class
you know i decided to self-produce this
album and
i knew this closer
feminist sex positions always hit hard
and was so powerful and i used the
resources i had so at the time um i
ended up opening for him many years
later but my buddy hari kondabolu always
had a bigger fan base than me
and so
he loved that bit and he told me flat
out and i was an early adopter of
youtube like i don't do i know exactly
what i was doing with it no but i would
put videos out and i was always doing
stuff with that because they were the
first original like video content place
and that's you know um so i
i was already putting stuff out on
youtube i already had maybe a couple
thousand followers and i remember hurry
being like when you put it out let me
know and i'll share it so and this is
also when social media
um they didn't have all their own um
video embedding so when you in when you
put a youtube link it would make it a
box like and you could watch it on it so
that was the other reason that this
youtube video went viral is because you
put it on twitter and it showed the box
as opposed to now they won't let it come
out because they want you to use
their own video embedding same with
facebook same with all the others so so
that's where concentrated views came
from but also was because hurry had a
big fan base he shared it
a couple other people shared it it was
a good bit and it was quality video and
the only reason i did it on this access
show that didn't pay well but you could
curse and i knew this bit was never
going to go on late night so i was like
i know this bit is good i want good
quality video for it and then i'm going
to give it a life on youtube and so i
think the mixture of me looking
professional because it was like you
know
an actual shoot and um good responses
and then having people kind of support
me you know it just takes a little bit
of a bump and it went i mean oh and then
i emailed every
feminist blog i could think of like i
googled some i knew some hurry actually
gave me the emails to a couple of people
but it was this i the people that broke
it the people that first really shared
it was called like everyday feminism and
i filled out their thing wrong like
their thing was like why do you want to
be a writer for everyday feminist and i
was like i don't i just have this video
and they're just like what do you love
about everyday feminism i was like it's
every day but can you watch this video
like i just you know what i mean like i
just wanted them to and somebody did and
they shared it and it got like 200 000
views in like a day and then it just
kind of took off and then it got picked
up by you know um uh uh cosmopolitan
magazine it got like it got picked up by
all these other kind of blogs and
whatever and then viral kind of read it
thing and you know and then also what
you have to understand is um it's a
benefit now
people hate women
and they get very mad
when you're successful and when you're
trying to be funny and hate comments and
thumbs down
work the same as engaging as
any kind of engagement so almost every
viral video i have if you look at the
comments it's about
70 30 of people enjoying it and not
enjoying it and i would say it's mostly
people not enjoying it wow but they hate
sharing it they hate watching it and
what it does is it pushes up to the
people that are gonna find it so
sometimes the beginning is clearly fans
and friends and they're going i love
this this is so great and then i
actually start to know when something
goes viral when i start to get people
being like uh she's ugly she should kill
herself go back to the kitchen women
aren't funny and then i'm like i get
excited i was like oh it's outside my
fan base and so like even right now um
it's not on my page it's on i'm i'm
headlining at um the punch line in san
francisco so they've been sharing
randomly my videos and they shared a
video and i just started getting a [__]
ton of followers and i was like oh it's
weird because my videos are doing okay
but they're not doing great and then i
started seeing like mean comments and i
was like oh they reshared this old video
so i look and it has like 600 000 views
right now wow you know what i mean and
i'm getting thousands of followers from
it but i'm also getting people telling
me to go back to the kitchen and they
actually this is this makes me laugh
i called my best friend because it made
me laugh so hard i was like having kind
of like a rough week i was just really
overwhelmed and so i just wanted to see
how well this video was doing because it
was kind of nice that i was getting
followers so i look and it's all these
mean comments and i read this comment
and it was like uh this isn't funny and
she's not hot and i was like well that
hurts my feelings and then i reread it
and it actually said she's not funny but
she's hot and then all these comments
below it were like yeah hot people can't
be funny and i was like oh
they were trying to hurt me but it
actually made me stronger i was like i
like left the house i was like i'm hot
today people people that don't find me
funny at least think i'm hot but it was
like it was one of these things where i
was just like that felt good because i
know i'm funny i might not be for you
you might not find me funny but i know
i'm funny so you can't hurt me with
saying this is garbage because you're
wrong i know i'm funny you not liking me
that's 100 understandable i am not for
everybody
but i am funny so then everything
outside of that you know
is debatable i have good i have pretty
days and i have bad days and i like the
idea that somebody's just like all right
not for me but she's got nice eyes and i
was like thank you sir that's a share
that's engagement
but what they don't understand is all
that stuff helps i really do not care
what you say about me it all helps you
know i you know don't be violent i mean
that stuff scares me but like genuinely
i
i was telling a couple of comics the
other week my favorite hate comment of
all time and i should have responded but
i was also in a place where i was like
i'm not i'm not engaging with these
people
this guy wrote back um
go make me a sandwich under one of my
videos
and his profile picture probably in this
guy's bald in his 40s he has two little
twin girls behind him probably
five-year-olds and it took everything
inside of me not to write it looks like
you have two little sandwich makers
behind you
because [__] you [__] you i can't
believe you're raising girls like [__]
you you piece of [__] and that's the
thing is that people don't understand
like people really don't understand
misogyny in this country like or in the
world really there are people that have
wives and girlfriends and daughters that
go around thinking i'm supportive of
women you're not though you're not i
can't tell you how many people do not
like that i'm doing something either
they want to be doing or doing something
that makes them feel threatened and it's
like i'm not threatening you you could
absolutely do this if you wanted to if
you chose not to do this this is not my
problem and then there's people that
don't find me funny and that's fine but
i've never left a hate comment in my
life
do you want to know why
because i'm doing what i want to do i
don't have time to be shitty to people
i've seen stuff i don't like i've
absolutely watched a comic and been like
this is trash
but worst i call my best friend and go
watch this trash
then you shared it anyway yeah and they
got they got a view good for you i can't
believe you got on fallon with all this
trash oh i've seen a few of those yeah
but at the same time you know i'm not
gonna bully anybody
and also i'm living my life i don't care
i really don't care it's 10 minutes of
me going like really but then i go on
with my life so every hate comment is
just somebody not doing what they
actually want to be doing in any aspect
of their life so and like it's funny my
little sister is a singer-songwriter and
she wants to like post more and put her
put more of her music out but she's
scared and i was like
you will never feel
full if you don't take the risk
in any quest it doesn't have to be with
posting just doing what you want to do
just working on music every day or
sharing your music with your friends or
whatever it is your goal but you are
always going to feel somewhat pulled
back and somewhat not living your
fulfilled life if there are things you
want to be doing and you're not doing
them because you're scared there was
always a risk but you know even with
social media people are like well i put
what if i post it and nobody likes it
well nobody saw it
who cares
who cares and then well what if i post
it in summary season they don't like it
who cares yeah it's all reps i mean i've
interviewed countless social media
comedians on here with like millions of
followers and
it comes down to like yes i can give you
these tips that worked for me but you
literally you you have to post you have
to create you have to share you have to
experiment like it comes down to that
yeah absolutely and the other thing is
is i am being myself and seeing and
trying to find the people that like it i
don't really change who i am for social
media or the audiences i might take in
data and information to see where the
joke's gonna go or whatever but i'm
writing about what i wanna write i'm
talking about what i wanna talk and i'm
posting what i wanna i post a cat
picture every saturday for caturday
nobody wants that nobody's asked for
that
and what's really nice is over the years
before i even wrote my book which is
called why cats are [__] but before
i even wrote that i accidentally was
like promoting this future book because
i would have people be like hey i
followed you for the comedy i stay for
the cats so my anytime i see a cat
outside i'm taking pictures every i try
to only post pictures on saturday for
caturday so it's not overwhelming but
it's i'm a crazy cat lady i have cat
jokes i you know the book came from
someone singing the cat jokes right
exactly so so this um editor uh
has two cats with his wife he wanted
somebody to write a book about why cats
suck but from a loving perspective and
he was looking every everywhere and then
he stumbled across one of my cat jokes
one of my favorite ones which is
basically the thesis of it is um nobody
nobody wants a cat like something bad
has to happen to you and they kind of
fall into your life
so
he found that joke he really liked he
brought me in for a meeting i remember
my manager at the time was just like hey
do you want a meeting with this person i
was like i've been waiting for this
meeting i've been waiting for somebody
this is the only thing i know anything
about so i had a meeting i told him how
i would write it he was like that's
great and then i you know i didn't even
have to go through a lit agent um it was
awesome and it's been such a great
experience and fans have been wonderful
about it like and like i said i
accidentally had been doing promo so
when i said i came out with catbook half
my audience is like of course you did
you know what i mean like of course of
course this is the next step for you so
it was um it was a great way to
clearly take every cat joke i've ever
made and put it on paper but also to
just stretch this other side of my
abilities and i went to school for
writing so i never thought i'd write
anything more than like a two-minute bit
so it was kind of cool to do that as
well and and and build up a different
level of confidence in my in my writing
and that was your degree was in writing
is that what you got a degree in yeah
okay yeah i meant to ask about that when
you start at 16 but then you still go to
college i was like oh interesting
usually i would have dropped out if i
knew sooner or
get this i'm going to drop later but it
didn't happen but i
i
am i
i'm like 50 50 glad i went i made some
great friends i read some great books
i've you know i'm still friends with a
couple professors i can see how some of
the classes had an influence like i took
this one of the mandatory classes was
persuasive writing and every joke of
mine is persuasive writing like you
don't know me you don't really
understand my background and who i am
but i'm going to show you why i'm right
how do you do that
you know for me it's about giving the
the bear you need to give enough
information that somebody understands
your perspective while not overloading
the information and boring them and then
also making the information interesting
and funny so like you know i have a joke
from my last special about um i go you
know i took xanax for the first time oh
if you don't know what xanax is it's
anti-inflammatory for for your um oh
[__] for your anti-inflammatory for your
hopes and dreams or your thoughts and
feelings that's what it is
anti-inflammatory for your thoughts and
feelings um
and to me
one it stemmed because i wrote that joke
when i was in england and my my agent in
england was like we don't label our
drugs like you guys in the u.s so we
don't know what xanax is so you have to
explain it to somebody so if i'm going
to have to take a moment to explain it
i'm going to try to make it as funny as
possible
so then that's where having vet parents
and knowing what an anti-inflammatory is
but then also knowing what what xanax
does which is it really does help you
with anxiety and get you out of your
thoughts and feelings so it's like i was
able to
you know step back make a definition do
a joke in the definition and then go
back into the joke so almost everything
i'm doing if i'm telling you something
that you know the first the first
joke the first time i write the joke
it's verbatim what i'm thinking so it's
just like guy cut me off in traffic i
hope he dies in a fire you know what i
mean is it a good feeling absolutely we
all felt that way i know that's going to
connect but is is it creative absolutely
not so then it's um setting up the scene
whether it's setting up how my day went
and why i was so angry setting up my
life and why i'm everything in my life
is somebody cutting me off and you know
doing something to and this is the last
straw and then
a creative way of telling someone to go
[__] themselves so you know what i mean
so that every aspect of the joke is you
agreeing with me even if you wouldn't
have done it yourself you agreeing with
me understanding why i did what i did
and then laughing at how i did it oh
interesting you almost put all your
jokes through that like checklist now i
guess pretty much wow so it's like how
what was it again how you feel about it
what happened so so sorry no it's okay
what kind of information you need to be
on my side okay so what you know they
see me so i don't have to tell someone
i'm a woman i don't have to tell
somebody that um sometimes my age will
get thrown in there um but sometimes a
previous joke has already said it so
that has to be there sometimes being a
new yorker might need to be in that so
sometimes you're picking back on the
information you've put up in the but
let's pretend it's the first joke of of
the set
um what information do they need
and then um um
how do i get them on my side
and then whatever i did say or you know
sometimes i like to think i'm a funny
person it's already funny and i don't
need i just need to make the setup funny
yeah um but sometimes what i said in
real life was like i'll [__] kill
your family and that's just aggressive
and how do we make that hilarious or how
do we make that like i have this new
joke about um
ups just like not delivering any of my
packages so like having being on the
phone with them and just how awful that
is and that's pretty relatable but i
still make every part of it funny and
then i talk about how the thing gets
solved but i still can't let it go i'm
seething i'm sitting i'm sitting on my
couch like i'm just so i'm i think of my
therapist she would tell me to go for a
walk so i go for a walk but then i see a
ups truck and i'm like i'll kill your
family like and i just show like and i'm
building up tension of the fact but like
even when i say something that is
anybody can say i'll kill your family
it's i've set it up to be like uh the
funny part of the joke or the unexpected
part of the joke so if something if me
being angry is already expected how do
we make that as funny as possible yeah
you almost set up the anger at the
beginning and then the punch line is
like how angry you actually get
absolutely gotcha but you i think over
and over again
and you and now i don't have to like
think about it i can see it on stage oh
they haven't laughed for like 30 seconds
or hey i said that and while that might
be smart they didn't laugh or you know
i'm gonna be specifically boring here so
that when i do the punch line it'll
really pop off but like everything has
every word i use and the order i use it
in all has a reason
of course yeah and i think young comics
early on that word economy is just so
overlooked or they think there's just
attitude behind everything but it's
really the writing is where the laughs
come in for sure yeah and like sometimes
you get this huge laugh but
i was bored half the time
what are we doing here like i can't tell
you how many times i watch a comic and i
go
i it was it was good but but we gotta we
gotta edit bud and then also i think
it's funny that you get one laugh and
then you drop off
you could go so much further like why
you just spent all this time you just
built up this you just did all this in
the premise and you just got one punch
line
why waste all you know what i mean yeah
it's like when you like you know how you
buy celery you only need like one piece
or two pieces of celery but you can't
just buy a stick of celery some place
you can buy just one carrot so now you
know for the rest of the week you're
like i'll put it in a salad i'm gonna
put peanut butter on it like you know
what i mean i'm like you have the whole
stock of celery use it everywhere and
that's where callbacks come in and you
know i like the layering of stuff i
think that's where i get most excited
and you know
something will be some something will
happen in my life and it'll be one line
and it's so exciting when all of a
sudden i was like oh man i got six punch
lines out of this like one line yeah i
love that so it's like i think for me um
i just find it so funny that there's
like beeping and there's music going on
i know and i can't wait to hear somebody
be like this is great but i think i'm
having a seizure
you know i wonder what that
is just like a low-grade fire that we're
just sitting through yeah yeah we're
just at a low-grade fire here yeah we're
taking risks for you guys
i don't wasn't there the whole time i
don't think i definitely don't think so
i feel like it won't get picked up as
much on here okay that's good
famous last words yeah yeah but i wonder
yeah just
we should have evacuated hours ago
interesting if that is a fire alarm that
is the least aggressive fire alarm ever
it's just like a tone that people over a
certain age wouldn't hear anyway yeah
i'm assuming everybody over 50 is that's
what i was thinking over 50 yeah yeah
yeah
well um
before we before we land this plane um
there were there were two more things
the one thing i ask always comics is
like their worst boo story or their
worst bombing story like a show you just
never forget like what's that for you
i have two okay um one was in jersey
i was
probably around nine ten years in i
opened for my buddy mark theobold it was
a college
and
he picked me up i've bombed at colleges
too
he picks me up i just have to do 20
minutes
um i get on stage
half attended
and this and i start talking i was very
i was still very monotone at the time so
i start talking and this guy goes
you're ugly
and i go
okay
trying to tell jokes i don't think
that's part of the process but thank you
and he goes your shoes are ugly and i
was like hey man i really like these
shoes like that really like that's a
little too far for me and then it was
just like your jacket's ugly like he
just literally and i was like what the
what the [__] is this so next thing i
know and keep in mind i'm like three
minutes into my set i rip this guy apart
like i get my first laughs ripping this
guy apart i'm like who the [__] are you
what the [__] is this college like what
are you gonna do when you grow up when
you're you have this personality and
this is where you so i'm like now
killing for five minutes i get them all
on my side but i now have what like over
10 minutes left so then i go back into
my act and i just bomb
for another 12 minutes because it's like
what i'm just gonna roast a guy for the
rest of it turns out that guy was like a
ta like he was like yeah it was crazy
but it was like he was really really
mean like i'm not doing justice to how
mean he was and then i ripped him apart
it went well and then i just bombed so
then i and then i get off stage mark
goes on stage he's like you're all right
i was like yeah i'm totally fine so now
i know i have like 45 minutes and so i'm
walking to the bathroom and i was like
don't cry don't cry don't cry don't cry
don't cry some girl was just like hey
what are you looking for i was like i'm
just looking for the bathroom she's like
it's over there and i was like cool i
was like don't cry don't cry and then i
cried for like 20 minutes in the
bathroom like just and then i was like
okay you have 20 minutes and i'm like a
snotter and i get blotchy and i was like
you have to
and then mark drove me home he's like
how you doing i'm great i'm great and
then um
i i said this to a friend once i was
just like have you ever bombed so hard
you got back together with an ex
because i went home and texted my ex and
i was like what are you doing
and i went and had sex with my ex like i
was like so [__] hurt
i was like oh my god like it was that
bad of a night that i was like i made so
many bad decisions because that guy hurt
my feelings it was bad and then my other
bad story
was the second time i was second or
third time i was in europe but it was
like my first european tour and this was
the last weekend of a month and a half
and when i say like the store i was in a
different city like every day i was it
was it was a long month and a half and
it was stressful and i'd never done
something like this before and so i'm in
leeds england
and it's it was this chain called
junglers so think like the improvs but
much shittier and i had done several of
these junglers and this one was in leeds
and it was a comedy club and then it
turned into a nightclub afterwards yes
yeah and so a lot of times people would
get in early because it was like cheaper
or whatever so they'd try out the comedy
night but they were really there to like
drink and [__] or whatever
they do so i'm again featuring i get on
stage i'm not even joking i was just
like so i'm from new york and they're
like no you're not
and i was like
i don't know if that's i don't know it's
debatable
because you don't know me and he goes
but you're here now and i go but that's
not where i'm from that's where i'm
physically am now i was like do you
understand how dumb what you're saying
is and i was like also like could you
let me talk so i'm like i don't want to
talk to this man so then i start going
into my and he starts interrupting me
again
and i was like what are we what are we
doing here what are your what's your
goal what's your hopes what's your
dreams like what are we doing and so i
go back and forth but it's nobody's
laughing it's just me arguing with this
drunk british guy
um i do that for about five minutes
start doing my act again he interrupts
people are rowdy nobody's listening it
was i think they lit me early i think it
was like the longest 15 minutes of my
life
um then somebody else went i didn't even
watch them i got all the junk food all
the junk food i was just like england
what do you have to offer in your 24
hour grocery store and i got all the
junk food and what really sucked is i
missed my brother's 21st birthday like
everybody was like hanging out and
getting drunk and like having fun and i
was bombing in leads and i was like i
could be home with my brother man
but it was like it was like that every
night so that was the first night and
every night it was that kind of level
and now like people are like you know i
have a lot of british um fans and
they'll be coming to leeds and i was
like never like i was like i just can't
like i just don't know if i'll ever go
back
it was really bad we will lead you out
yeah like leave you out
okay anyway
and uh and the final thing and thank you
so much for your time in doing this um
the i have to ask about george carlin
because just so i run it because i did
wear his shirt today and that was not
it's incredible oh and the beeping came
back oh good okay good i was worried i
was like good the beeping stuff yeah we
want consistency yeah exactly so
the the george carlin situation i mean
you emailed or
mailed like wrote to 40 different people
in comedy when you started you heard
back from judd apatow and george carlin
yeah i think judd responded like gave
you some like
keep going or what not but george you
like created like a relationship with
right yeah so it's kind of crazy so i i
my dad told me to write a business
letter so some people had emails judd
but he was it was post freaks and geeks
and around undeclared times but it was
way before 40 year old virgin and how we
know judd now so i his email was still
on his website so i wrote him an email
being like i'm 15. i'm thinking about
doing stand-up do you have any advice
and he was very nice it was mostly like
stay in school i have a printed out
version of it
but i i found
a
address for george now you know i found
out that it was his he had an office he
would go to an office every day so i
found this address and i wrote it like a
business letter so it was my name my
address my phone number and my email and
then i wrote like hey i'm 15 i'm
thinking about getting to stand up i'm
you know
i love your work and if you have any
advice i'd really appreciate it
and he called he called my family home
you know this is before i had a cell
phone he called my house
and he was like hey it's liz there and i
was like yeah he goes it's george carlin
and i just you know this is how old i am
the phone is attached to the wall i just
slid down the wall
and i was like and i'm one of five kids
it's very rare that i'm in a house by
myself but it was like
a saturday and like people had soccer
and you know you know my parents worked
on the weekends and so i'm like by
myself i was like folding laundry and i
was like
and there's a lot of mental illness in
my family my first thought was like oh
my god this is my first psychotic break
it's so exciting like i was like excited
you know what i mean like i was like
grandma was crazy i can't wait to be
crazy but i was like oh my god oh my god
oh my god and so um
he talks to me for 10 minutes and he's
like you can you can write to me anytime
um i called my dad immediately told him
what happened this was actually really
great advice my dad told me to
immediately write down everything he
said so i didn't forget it so i have i
have a card from you know 2001 that's
like george carlin phone call this is
what he said it was nothing mind-blowing
but it was
a legend telling me and with his own
words and so i did i wrote to him a
couple of times i was featured in the
new yorker when i was 19 and i mailed
him the magazine and he called me up to
be like i read it that's so cool i
didn't know what barking was because you
know oh wow yeah like um
and that was what the article was about
it's like these young comics handing out
flyers in the city um
and then when i was nine and then he
sent me a week after um he called me he
sent me a signed headshot that said go
do it because i hadn't done stand-up yet
and that's on my bookshelf um and
there's always been like on my desk and
stuff and then he sent me me and my my
girlfriend's a couple of free tickets to
see him in new brunswick because i lived
in jersey and then again so i had a
couple of phone calls with them a couple
of um letters and then i asked if we
could get coffee because i saw he was
touring nearby and so i met in the lobby
of his hotel and the biggest thing at
that time
is i didn't understand how you made your
jokes flow and how you went from bit to
bit because i'd only been doing it a
couple years and he took out his laptop
and he showed me his set list and and
how he would memorize things and there's
so many
technical influential things from that
meeting and he was just so generous with
his time and no even in the letters
because i printed out all the like
responses when i finally had his email
and the letters he never no question was
ever dumb he would be like oh i'm not
sure things might have changed but this
is what i do like he was super
thoughtful
and then after that meeting he gave me
his email and so i would um
email him um any i think he called maybe
one or two more times but
um
i was on comedy central my first tv
credit i was 22 years old and i did this
thing for comedy central and i emailed
him to be like hey i'm going to be on
comedy central on friday he's like i'm
absolutely watching and then he died two
days later oh man yeah he was in the
hospital and it's interesting because i
didn't know this
i went to an advanced screening of the
hbo documentary that his daughter and
judd and michael bonafiglo put together
and uh it was supposed to kind of be
like a routine thing like he had a bunch
of heart attacks and stuff but this was
kind of like a routine i'm going to
hospital for this thing even his wife at
the time you know didn't think anything
of it and he
didn't know that he was going to die you
know what i mean like it wasn't like
this rushed because he had been rushed
to the hospital a couple of times with
heart issues so um
yeah it was
it took me what i find fascinating is so
kind of
an addendum to this story is my buddy
brakash oh we're just hilarious
[Laughter]
you guys are done um
i like all the things that have gone
wrong with this i love this yeah and we
met at a hotel lobby like you met george
yeah
yeah i hope you feel influenced i do um
i'm not writing you any letters
um
but what's really interesting is so my
buddy prakash like early 2020 goes hey
there was this article saying that judd
apatow and
i i like being in the dark i was just
gonna turn this up yeah
oh hilarious yeah that's still going to
be dark yeah it's fun no it doesn't
matter they saw they they know what my
face is we're doing at a campfire yeah
yeah oh my god i get s'mores
um but he um my buddy burkash was like
hey judd apatow and michael bonafiglio
who both did um the gary shandling
documentary which if you haven't seen as
a four-part documentary on hbo um
is doing one on george carlin you should
reach out to him and i was like well i
don't really know judd um
and so i work at the cellar and i was
like
i want them to know how nice he was like
you know what i mean like he was such a
generous person and there's a little bit
of that in the gary shanley documentary
where they talk about like george comes
up and they talk about how nice he was
but um i reached out to este who's the
booker at the seller and i go hey this
might be a big ask but and i basically
told her the story because i don't think
she knew it and i go hey you know i did
this i wrote to two people i read to
judd and everyone took george and george
got back to me and i would love to just
tell judd that story and like send them
some of you know these
pictures and and you know um
uh letters and stuff just so they have
something because they used letters a
lot in gary shandling and i really like
the way they make stuff and she was like
this is beautiful i'm gonna forward it
to judd so she forwards it to judd judd
come back comes back and he goes oh i
hope i was a nice person when i wrote to
her and he goes go talk to michael
bonifigulo so i talked to michael mostly
but then i saw judd at the seller
because he's at the seller and i go hey
you know we kind of talked via estee but
i was the girl that you know was friends
with george carlin when i was a teenager
he's like oh that's so cool so now i've
seen him a couple of times they sent me
i
so they didn't end up interviewing me
because they actually got so like kelly
carl and his daughter had access to so
much of he like recorded so much and she
had access to everything that george
actually kind of tells his own story
almost so they do some comic interviews
but um i did voiceover for that like i
was they had a bunch of comics read
these letters he got from fans when he
went from being straight edged to being
more like hippy-dippy and aggressive and
so me and like gary goldman and a couple
other comedians read some of those fan
letters so i'm a small part in that and
then netflix did this thing called the
hall where they like had these greats
like you know joan rivers and george
carlin and richard pryor and stuff and
they interviewed me for that and so some
of this story is in that as well but i
ended up meeting judd i think like four
or five times now and they invited me to
the screening and i got to and i met
kelly a couple of times i met her like
10 years ago um and i've now met her
like three or four times she's a dream
she's just a sweet wonderful person so i
feel fortunate even that realm that like
even like judd wrote me back but now 20
years later you know i'm just like dad i
wrote you too um and he was really sweet
and and um
michael the other director is wonderful
so
i feel good that i can just because i've
always said this
clearly he's influenced so many people
and what he talks about and so many
comedians and just how incredible he is
and i highly recommend that hbo
documentary but the biggest influence
was how kind he was to somebody that
could never
repay him and somebody that was asking
kind of dumb questions you know what i
mean like i was a 16 year old girl that
was just like i just want to do this and
how do you do it and he's like oh this
is what i did and some other people do
this and i saw this website and this
might be helpful like
he was
beyond generous and even today like and
what's crazy about it is he was he was
in his 70s he was a living legend he was
still pretty busy um you know even five
or six seven years ago i mean i was busy
trying to survive but i was really busy
and i've always had him in the back of
my head which is
in some capacity i can help people now
there's people that take advantage of it
there's people that are shitty and i
don't feel like i have to get back to
everybody but if somebody is eager and
they're willing to do the work i'll
absolutely get back to people and i'm
i'm dyslexic so i actually do more voice
memos than write to people so like on
instagram i'll have somebody that's like
hey i saw you did this i just how did
you do that i'm kind of confused and
i'll be literally right i'm dyslexic
it's easier for me to do voice memos and
i'll just leave like four or five one
minute voice memos because that's the
max and and then they're all like excite
like and i clearly say more than i would
type because it takes me so long to type
but like i'm more than willing to share
my information and i was raised nice so
it's like i feel like i was raised as a
nice person i like being nice then i met
this incredibly influential person that
was the nicest person i've ever met all
my friends are nice now and then it's
about how do you
continue to be the person you want to be
in a business that's actually not very
nice
so it's been its own interesting hurdle
but i always kind of have him in the
back of my mind because you know
i do want to be him when i grow up in
every aspect i just think he was an
incredible person
well you're incredible for doing this
thank you yeah my pleasure taking the
time before your final show here in
atlanta um
i like i felt that that like moved me i
don't know why but i was like i was like
in there with you like listening to that
i really felt that that was a really
cool moment thanks for sharing that yeah
my pleasure um so please you mentioned
liking to help peeps where can people
like reach out to you where can they
check out all your awesome work yeah uh
everything is at liz mealy m-i-e-l-e and
then um i have a new special coming out
september 6th on youtube congrats yeah
did you still produce another one yeah i
did so i recorded it in april and um i'm
excited about it and um
uh um yeah so self-produced it'll be
album it'll be on youtube um so
subscribe to youtube that's where i feel
my happiness um
and i'm touring so all my tour dates um
are on my website and i'm constantly
adding to it and if you like cats go buy
my book boom
awesome well liz mealy thank you for
being on hot breath yeah thanks for
having me in the dark yeah
yeah
hot breath after dark hair yeah